I know that you don't like to talk about your life
but a guy with a freaking machete foreign
arm just chopped our butts in half
all my life i tried to forget my past
my dad in the ten rings on september 3rd you were
meant for greatness don't hide who you really are
i'm nothing like you hell yeah
who are you no that's not who i am
a marvel legend
will rise you got this
that's what i said
marvel studios shang chi and the legend of the
ten rings rated pg-13 in theater september 3rd
Welcome back everyone marvel released a new
shang chi trailer video with a whole bunch of
new abomination scenes so i'll explain his history
in the mcu after the events of the incredible hulk
where he's been this whole time and how this movie
crosses over with the events of doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness i'll explain the new marvel
phase 4 timeline because since loki wandavision
falcon and winter soldier the timeline has gotten
pretty crazy if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos we're in
the middle of marvel what if episodes right now
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up later this
year too we're still doing the weekly giveaway for
disney plus memberships details about that down in
the description below during the trailer there's
a lot more footage of shang chi and his father
the mandarin you see a lot more footage of him
rallying his army in front of that huge wall
carving depicting the ancient village that
sits between the lake here and the special seal
that the great protector dragon seems like it's
protecting you see him use the power of the ten
rings a bunch more like you can actually see the
rings around his arms here as he's fighting his
father the mandarin the whole idea of the movie is
him learning about the true history of his family
and his connection to the ten rings of power and
in the trailer the mandarin says now the ten rings
are calling to you so he's going to learn about
his special connection to them and the way that
they're sort of changing them for the mcu they'll
be a little bit different from the comic book
version of the 10 rings they also have that funny
tag scene calling out the true pronunciation of
his name like wait a minute how do you pronounce
it i've been saying it wrong this whole time all
these years but speaking of dragons getting to the
abomination of it all a lot of you are asking why
the abomination kind of looks a little bit like a
dragon here with the fins and why his appearance
changed so if it wasn't clear or you haven't read
a lot of classic hulk comics the abomination
emil blonsky actually looks like this in the
comics the shang chi movie version of abomination
is the comic book accurate looking version i think
a lot of people were just confused because it's
been so long since they've read those classical
comics or you just haven't seen abomination in a
long time in the comics the main reason why they
didn't make him look like this during incredible
hulk back in 2008 was the director said that he
tried to argue that the hulk would have snapped
the fins off during their first fight and i also
think that they were trying to really play it
safe with how weird they got with that movie
everybody remembers the story about how they were
on the verge of bankruptcy if the first iron man
movie and the incredible hulk movie didn't perform
at the box office they were going to go bankrupt
and lose all their characters cut to present day
you have alligator loki probably one of the most
popular characters to come out of the loki series
in fact i'll go so far as to say is it the weirder
the marvel series have gotten in this past year
the more popular they are that's why loki is a
little bit more popular than wand division in
one division was more popular than falcon and
winter soldier but in the mcu they like to keep
the changes to characters across the timeline
in continuity so the in-universe story reason why
abomination looks so different now is just because
his gamma mutation just continued to evolve over
time at a slower rate also the hulk changes his
form based on different factors based on how mad
he gets he can also turn into professor hulk which
looks different physically from his incredible
hulk form so if hulk's body can change its hulk
state form at various times in the mcu so can
abomination the difference with abomination though
is that he can't change back into a human he's
trapped in this form i know during the preview
video for the she-hulk series last year when they
announced that abomination was coming back during
that they just showed tim roth's face along with
mark ruffalo is the hulk because he's also coming
back for her origin story i think the reason why
they did the preview that way though was because
they didn't want to spoil the abomination's
new look before the shang chi movie came out
so why is abomination fighting in this mortal
kombat tournament against wong and where has
he been this whole time what was he doing during
avengers infinity war and avengers end game here's
where we get to the thunderbolt ross weapons plus
contessa valentina val madam hydra whatever you
want to call her of it all also spoilers for the
black widow post credit scene if you haven't seen
that because that's relevant for what's going on
with this rewind to falcon and winter soldier we
see that baron zemo gets thrown in the raft
which is thunderbolt ross's personal prison
for superheroes super villains anyone who's too
powerful to be kept in regular prison from val's
connections to zemo the fact that she's working
for some shady figure inside the us government
it's probably thunderbolt ross we know she's going
around recruiting anti-heroes and marvel villains
so we're all just kind of waiting for her to show
up out of the shadows and recruit abomination for
her team but rewind to 2008 in the marvel timeline
after the events of the incredible hulk movie both
the abomination and the leader get arrested
by thunderbolt ross and thrown in the prison
i know you're asking where is the leader kevin
feige said that he's still alive in the mcu
the de facto explainer for any big marvel
villain that you haven't seen in a long time
and was defeated at the end of a marvel movie
is there probably chilling out inside the raft
so they could bring the leader back anytime that
they want but both of them get thrown in the raft
where they stay for all of the marvel phase 1
phase 2 and phase 3 movies so now you ask how
did abomination wind up in what seems like beijing
china where this fight seems like it's happening
and what is he going to be doing later in the
timeline when he shows up in the she-hulk series
so it's all about the snap avengers infinity
war the five year time jump in avengers end game
a lot of the big twists of marvel phase four are
still turning on what happened with avengers end
game even the loki series which is now teasing
the next big marvel phase four threat in kang
in the multiverse war that all started with a big
twist from avengers end game but the idea with the
abomination is that he probably was not snapped
and used the confusion that happened while the
snap was going on people being dusted all around
him inside the raft guards as well to escape and
he just been on the dl running around different
countries trying to keep up with thunderbolt
ross's radar the same way that banners hulk was
doing before the events of the first avengers
movie you have to remember he's a hulk character
so a lot of what's happening with the abomination
is probably big deep cut easter eggs for whole
comic books the shang chi movie takes place after
avengers end game but before the events of the
she-hulk series and before the events of doctor
strange 2 because of what's going on with wong
and the reason why he's probably hiding out in
china is because the u.s government the military
thunderbolt ross wouldn't have jurisdiction there
so as long as he's not causing trouble for the
chinese government they're not going to touch him
so abomination is probably only in the movie for
a little while not a major character like he takes
off on the run again and then shows up again
during the events of the she-hulk series like
he beats wong's ass then the tournament gets shut
down and he just takes off running again so that
he doesn't get caught it is probably during the
she-hulk series later in the timeline when they'll
reveal that he's either already working for val
madame hydra just like elena bulova has been
like john walker us agent it's also implied baron
zemo is going to be working with her too and it's
just their thunderbolts team coming together in
a bigger way so it's sort of like them giving the
abomination a version of that john walker us agent
ending scene from the falcon and winter soldier
i know a lot of you are wondering if one of the
shang chi post-credits scenes will be val showing
up to recruit him but it seems like he's such a
minor character they might just save that scene
of her recruiting him for the she-hulk series but
now talking about the doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness crossover with wong so this movie
takes place before the events of spiderman no way
home in doctor strange 2 because both of those two
movies are kind of like a one-two multiverse punch
but the shang chi movie is supposed to be
happening after the events of falcon and
winter soldier so right now the order of the
marvel shows during phase four goes like this
it starts with avengers end game then loki happens
then one division right after that then the events
of the black widow post-credits scene with elena
beloved val then a little while after that the
events of falcon and winter soldier happen and
that's around six months after avengers end game
spider-man far from home takes place about eight
months after avengers end game the events of the
shang chi movie would take place a little while
after that because we know spiderman no way home
takes place the christmas holiday right after the
events of spider-man far from home then the events
of doctor strange 2 would take place right after
that so there's probably at least a few months
between shang chi and wong's fight here with the
abomination in the events of doctor strange 2
now the writer of doctor strange 2 said that
during that movie they're supposed to be at
the height of their powers that includes doctor
strange scarlet witch and obviously wong too
so even though everyone's making the sandwich
money jokes about wong gotta get that sandwich
money somehow it's more likely that he's just
fighting in the tournament for fun just to test
himself after avengers end game like he has
his own hobbies his own things that he likes
to do in his free time when he has it and after
abomination hands him his ass and he slinks back
to the sanctum i'm sure doctor strange will just
make some jokes about it like what happened to you
but i think other than just teasing doctor
strange 2 and teasing abomination coming back
for thunderbolts crossover with val they also
want abomination to win here to come off super
powerful so that it hypes up his rematch with
the hulk during the she-hulk series marvel will
also be revealing more of their brand new disney
plus series that they haven't announced yet later
this year so hopefully that presentation will
get some more hints about what's happening with
thunderbolt in the mcu and some of the other big
rumors about other series that they're working on
everyone let me know in the comments how do you
think abomination escaped the raft after avengers
infinity war and when do you think that val is
going to recruit him for her thunderbolts team
my full marvel what if episode 2 video will
post wednesday just like normal it's going to
be the black panther t'challa star lord episode
click here for my full marvel what if episode 1
video in easter eggs and click here for my what
if episode 2 trailer video with black panther
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!